Aaron Sampson here with a starter guide
for the titanfall beta with the close
titanfall beta set to run from Friday
February 14th to Wednesday February 19th
some of you will most certainly find
yourself in the chest area of one of
these walking monstrosity if you care to
be the thing that punches the squishy
things on the ground and not the squishy
thing that gets punched then you should
pay attention for starters there are
three modes in the build of titanfall
that we previewed attrition which is
team deathmatch hardpoint domination
which is conquest and last Titan
standing which is destroy the mechanical
things to win both attrition and
hardpoint domination will see you
leaping out of a dropship and saddled
with a four minute countdown timer until
you get your Titan you can shorten this
time by killing creep other pilots and
later on by rodeoing enemy titans holy
crap look how fast that rodeo bleeds the
countdown timer when that timer does run
down you may call in one of three
classes of Titans the Atlas which is the
one most likely to be in the beta comes
in assault tank in artillery
specializations so which one do you want
to be in that depends on what map you're
playing the assault and artillery
variants of the Atlas are great for
close quarters urban warfare on Angel
City
the artillery variant puts out immense
damage at close range with circular
volleys of Rocky's these rockets travel
too slowly to have an effect on longer
sightlines so contrary to what our
Tillery does in real life think of this
class as a close quarters bruiser the
assault variant is also good on Angel
City and as an all-around fighter
utilizing the EXO 16 chain gun the chain
guns rate of fire also makes it one of
the more effective weapons against
dismounted pilots the titan also comes
with an auto eject feature which means
you won't end up like this guy
as a bonus the auto reject also chips
your pilots cloak power to see you
safely away or just land on the Titan
that killed you and Rodeo it to death
now let's talk about the tank variant of
the Atlas this beauty sports a 40
millimeter cannon that works like a DMR
for this reason you should take the tank
out for a spin on the fracture map the
tank also comes stock with a nuclear
ejection feature which is amazing here's
how it works if you find yourself
outnumbered and getting gang beat by
enemy Titans lure them closer now closer
even closer now flip the bird is you
eject and watch them explode as your
Titan self destructs haha you live all
three variants also come with the bullet
catchy vortex shield which vacuums up
incoming fire and returns it to its
owner be careful with the return part
lest you end up playing past the bombs
with an enemy Titan and then running out
of catch juice also if you see an enemy
Titan deploy the vortex shield
I'd recommend holding your fire there's
nothing more satisfying than shooting an
enemy Titan making it mad catching its
bullets and then throwing them back in
its face starting at level 10 you'll
unlock custom slots and can get your big
metal paws on slave warheads that
replace rocket salvo and also electric
smoke that replaces vortex shield
Electric smoke releases a burning cloud
into the air and is great for frying
enemy pilots who are busy pulling out
your neck gizzards damaging an enemy
Titan during a fist fight or for
entering a capture point and then
denying access to it for dismounts now
let's talk about titan combat a fight
between two titans is about managing
distance not forgetting to use cover
like you would as a pilot paying
attention to shields in the same way you
wouldn't say halo and knowing when to go
in and rip out a Titans pilots beating
heart make sure you know when to engage
and when to run away because Titans can
be killed fairly easily for more
advanced tactics calling a Titan fall on
an enemy Titan and watch it be crushed
like an actor on sharknado if you see a
friendly Titan about to lose drop your
Titan in front of it has a Titan lands
it deploys a large temporary shield that
can act as cover for your team later
level unlocks
increase the amount of time that shield
is deployed speaking of now that your
Titan is on the ground but far away from
you
set the Titan to follow you or garden
area it won't be as effective at combat
as when you're in it but there's a
couple scenarios where they'll give you
an advantage in hardpoint domination
matches usually one of the capture
points can be reached by titans directly
but not so much for the others leaving
your Titan to guard the outside while
you capture from within is a must
it'll even drop you off on the second
story thanks Titan you will also have to
ditch your Titan when you're getting
rodeoed by enemy pilots the only way to
kill them is to get out and do it
manually do not set your Titan to patrol
when you get out it'll only make the
enemy pilot into a moving target
if the enemy pilot is smarting gets off
to fight you then tell your Titan to
join the fray and light that pile it up
if you died don't worry you're tight and
will fight on in your honour the last
reason to ditch your Titan is to create
a diversion in the epilogue portion of
matches the epilogue is the part at the
end of a match where the winning team
has to chase the losing team to a
dropship everyone has one life and the
objective for the losing team is to get
out alive the dropship can be destroyed
by direct damage so protective as long
as possible
holding out as long as you can in your
Titan and then leaving it to fend for
itself could buy you a few precious
seconds that make you the only person
off the planet large point bonuses are
awarded for teams who can get all their
players spirited away safely but good
luck with that as a matter of fact keep
an eye on the match score if you're
about to lose get to the dropship pickup
point before the epilogue kicks in
there's so much more to talk about in
titanfall hell we didn't even get into
pilots while jumping across the math
donkey kicking players in midair all of
these more shall be yours soon so stay
tuned to game spot for more titanfall
coverage
you